hey you guys flickers of fear once again
my humble little movie review show
movie we're talking about today
this was
a cool one i really really like this
movie but i am gonna say that
this is one of those ones that you're
either gonna vibe with it or you're not
gonna vibe with it it seems like it's
very very divisive i did see a lot of
reviews of this this seemed like it was
very very critically popular you know
like a lot of critics really seem to
love it uh some audiences really really
hated it
and i get that but
as i said this is one that's either
gonna vibe with you or it's not uh just
personally for me uh this movie vibed
with me like a [ __ ] it was just
kind of like every single thing i like
about movies was in this movie so i just
like couldn't believe i was like oh my
god it's it almost seemed like this
movie was made for like me specifically
which is crazy
so this movie is called in fabric it
came out in 2018 although i think it
wasn't released in the us until a year
later
and it's a british film
i had been seeing it uh turn up on all
these kind of like best of 2019 lists
and the premise of it sounded really
intriguing in the sense that they're
like well it's kind of like a giallo
infused euro trash kind of movie about a
haunted dress and i was just kind of
like
that sounds like something i need to
investigate
so i'd been wanting to see it for a
really long time so i finally got around
to watching it and uh prior to watching
it i was not aware that this was
actually written and directed by peter
strickland who also wrote and directed
barbarian sound studio which i reviewed
a while back would you like a giallo
homage which i also really loved as well
that came out back in 2012. he's also
done another movie uh called the duke of
burgundy that came out in 2014
and that again is kind of like an homage
to
some of those like old 60s and 70s like
eurosleys type movies and so that's
definitely on my list as well uh
particularly because barbarian sound
studio was so great and particularly
because in fabric i mean i just i adored
this movie i just thought it was amazing
but
again um it's very arty uh a24 uh is you
know did it in the us
and
it's very
surreal
it's a black comedy but the comedy it's
british so it's kind of like the humor
is just very very dry and some of it is
almost kind of like cringe comedy kind
of territory so i kind of feel like one
of the main criticisms that i saw of
like a lot of people that really didn't
like it per in particular like american
uh reviewers or you know youtubers or
whoever
is they didn't really
find it funny so it is like a particular
you have to have kind of like a
particularly weird sense of humor
i actually thought it was parts that
were quite hilarious but as i said it's
not over the top
i think the wikipedia page does actually
call it a horror comedy and i don't know
i kind of feel like when people say
horror comedy they usually mean like
something
zanier kind of you know what i mean like
more like you know tucker and dale
versus evil or even sean of the dead or
something like that this is a much more
dry
uh very very dark like morbid witty kind
of humor
rather than
overtly funny you know what i mean it's
it's almost kind of like and like i said
it almost has like
cringe comedy like the original british
version of the office like type stuff
where it's just these really awkward
situations um and just like absurd
uh you know just absurd situations in
general
so uh so there's that to it as well this
is a weird
weird movie and coming from me
that's really saying something
uh but it's weird it's bizarre it
doesn't really explain itself
but
it doesn't really need to i do kind of
feel like a lot of people that saw this
were just kind of like well i didn't
really get it like or i didn't really
know
what was supposed to be going on and
honestly i don't
i think it's better not knowing i mean i
have some ideas about what was going on
but it's it's better not to know i
thought it was like better that it was
just kind of this weird like mysterious
whatever and you could kind of like draw
your own conclusions so the movie
is kind of like you know comparisons to
suspiria the original dario argento one
are inevitable this is a very it's not a
giallo movie and it's not even
homogeneous movie but
the look of this is very giallo esque it
has these really sumptuous
uh you know kind of tactile
uh colors and it's just kind of all this
you know the sound design and all this
other stuff so it has that kind of thing
to it and it also kind of has that sort
of like retro euro sleeves sort of
sensibility to it but it's also kind of
homaging british horror films
particularly the 60s and 70s like in
your hammer films your amicus like
anthology films it almost kind of seems
like that it has a tinge of maybe black
mirror uh to it and i've seen it kind of
you know a lot of people say oh it's
david lynchian it in the sense that
surreal it is but it's not really like
david lynch at all it kind of reminded
me more of something like i don't know
like ken russell or something like that
it's just a very
like i said it's a very surrealist
nightmarish but also like kind of funny
like funny slash unsettling it's really
really hard to describe it is a bizarre
bizarre film but i
[ __ ] loved it
but i can see as i said that it's going
to be very divisive because it's one of
those movies that people are just kind
of like
like what was the point of it i didn't
know what the [ __ ] was going on it was
style over substance yada yada i've seen
like a lot of different criticisms of it
but honestly i loved it and the more i
think about it i watched it early
yesterday and i've been thinking about
it the whole time and i'm like now i
kind of want to watch it again you know
what i mean and i was watching like
another review of it and they said yeah
like watch it a second time too because
it's even better then because you can
just kind of because you already know
that it's going to be like super bizarro
so it's just kind of like you can just
relax and kind of like let it wash over
you so i definitely think that i'm going
to take that on board and i'm going to
end up watching this again one day
because this is definitely one that i'm
gonna want to see again because i really
really liked it so much the first time
so what we have in this movie let me see
if i can kind of break this down for you
a little bit
so uh
we're introduced to our kind of main
character his name is sheila she's
played by marianne john baptiste who
i've seen her in a lot of stuff but i
think she was like the most recognizable
to me from uh secrets and lies the mike
lee movie uh back in the 90s and she
actually got nominated for an oscar for
that i don't think she won but uh that's
a great movie by the way if you haven't
seen it i love mike lee and uh you know
so
so this like i said it has this is a
very very british movie i mean peter
strickland is british and he's kind of
seems particularly tuned into
this specific sort of british absurdity
i guess so as i said this is a very very
british film so sheila who's played by
marianne jean baptiste
she has her husband has uh left her he's
like run off with a younger woman
presumably and she's kind of like left
at home with her teenage son
who's kind of a dick actually uh you
know very dismissive of her
and the son is has a girlfriend
who is also
very uh snotty and kind of like she's
always kind of like
staying at their house and not really
helping out with anything she just seems
like she's very she's always kind of
like bossing the mom around and just
being really i don't know she's like
really an [ __ ]
so the two of them are in there uh poor
sheila is
you know as i said she's single and she
seems like she hasn't really gotten over
it and she works in a bank like as a
bank teller
and
it's bad enough that she just got
divorced that her son and his girlfriend
are kind of taking over her house and
being jerks and then she works at the
bank and like she has the two guys that
like run the bank or the bank managers
or whatever
uh they're called stash and clive
and they keep like bringing her into the
office to
presumably it seems like they're saying
nice things like oh you you're doing
really well and blah blah blah but then
they start like excoriating her for like
really really weird like minor [ __ ] like
you know you spent two minutes too long
in the bathroom before lunchtime and
somebody was watching you and reported
you and then like later like the the
criticisms that they make of her just
get like weirder and weirder like as the
movie goes on like you waved at the bank
president's mistress in the street the
other day and she reported that because
she thought it was very like she was
like but she went back and she was
smiling i don't understand so it's just
like this really weird like absurdist
almost like a kafka type of thing where
there's kind of showing how
you know this this corporation doing
like all these nitpicky little things on
her
so she's decided that she's kind of
lonely right so she's gonna go she
starts doing this is okay the weird
thing about this too is that
i couldn't really get a handle on when
this is supposed to be set i don't think
it's supposed to be set in a particular
time because like i said
really continuity like you know
narrative focus wasn't really
a main concern it's definitely set at
some time in the past because judging by
um you know the answering machine like
on the phone and things like that i kind
of thought that it was maybe late 80s i
looked it up and supposedly it said in
1993.
the weird thing about it though is that
this movie is kind of like in two parts
it's one movie but the narrative like
halfway through like shifts to another
main character
and that second part
seems to be considering like what people
are wearing and things like that it
seems to be much later or much more
recent
but it's supposed to have happened like
very very soon after the first part so
don't get too hung up about when is this
supposed to be it's the past uh as i
said this is like a retro homage uh
movie so it's not too worried about when
particularly but it is just supposed to
be sometime in the past i thought late
80s or it could be early 90s i guess
like i said just compared to like what
the technology was and you know the way
the inside the house is looked and stuff
like that so since there was no uh
internet back then when when this movie
is supposed to be set
she decides sheila decides that she is
going to do like a lonely hearts type of
thing like in the newspaper so they do
this
and i remember this like in my own
lifetime but they used to have like
these you'd put in a classified ad and
then everybody had like a box number
because you know you didn't want like
weirdos like turn it up at your house
and stuff so everybody had like was
assigned a box number and then you ran
an ad they put your box number and the
people could send letters to your box
and then you go pick them up
so she starts doing that
and so she's gonna go on a date first
date since the divorce and she wants
something new and nice to wear so she
goes to this department store in the
high street in this in this town which
is called thames valley on thames which
i thought was very funny so like i said
if if you're really an anglophile and
you're into british stuff or if you are
british this will probably be much
funnier to you than it is to an american
but it's just because a lot of the jokes
are like real subtle and low-key like
that and a lot of them have to do with
particularly british things or like
british culture so if you don't know a
lot about that then some of the jokes
might not be funny to you because they
are like pretty subtle but just i don't
know stuff like that like amused the
[ __ ] out of me
so she lives in this town there's this
department store called dently and
supers
and this department store has the
[ __ ] the world's weirdest commercials
they're like these really weird
you know if you've ever watched like
this kind of like new retro wave kind of
channels or like if you've seen like
some of dan bell stuff where he does
like that real weird like he takes [ __ ]
from like infomercials and stuff and
does this weird so it's a very vapor
wavy type of situation so it's this
these commercials
and they're all kind of like these
creepy spinning mannequins and it's all
like this weird music and then they have
like all these sales women who are
wearing
what looks like victorian morning
clothes i'm talking about the whole full
on like the big [ __ ] skirts with the
hoops and all this like lace and
everything and they all have like this
real big hair these bouffants are like
big death rock things kind of going on
it's crazy so they're like so they're in
the ads and they're like luring
everything all these big big bright red
nails and they're like luring people
into the store it's just like the
weirdest thing you've ever seen
and so uh so yeah so she goes to this
department store
and she is kind of like looking around
and then she starts getting stalked by
this sales lady who's like the main
sales lady uh miss luckmore
now miss luckmore again has olives has
this big huge like black bouffant and
she's like this big like victorian black
victorian dress and she says like all
this really weird [ __ ] like i can't even
remember
she has like all this like retail
patter but she says it in like this
really
verbose baroque kind of language and
it's just
it's kind of like a running gag i want
to say but it's just kind of like the
[ __ ] that she says is just [ __ ] crazy
and it's crazy too because she says
these really like poetic like i said
really verbose type of things
and
everybody else acts like like sheila
who's act like a normal person she
reacts to that like it's kind of normal
you know what i mean so i th which makes
it funnier to me but there's just like
all this really weird [ __ ] in this store
like when you buy something you're
waiting for your change like you have to
she has to put the money you give her
the money she puts the money in this
little tiny little cylinder thing like
at a bank that goes up the pipe you know
and she puts it in there and it goes up
and then while she's waiting for your
change to come back down the pipe she
just stares at you and you stare at her
and it's just like and it's almost like
this really weird like long like
hypnosis type of thing going on it's
like so [ __ ] weird okay so sheila
goes to this store
and she sees this
dress and she gets talked into buying it
now this dress is like
red like really red and uh the catalog
says artery red which i love
uh it's this silk wrap dress
and it's kind of again kind of like this
movie it's not any particular
style you know what i'm saying it's kind
of old-fashioned but not really like
maybe you can still kind of wear it's
very like vague as to when it's when it
kind of came from when it was in fashion
so this bright red dress it's got kind
of these long sort of like puffy chiffon
type sleeves it's made of silk and it's
only kind of uh embellishment is it has
like this black rose or something like
that like on one hip
and on the inside of the seam there's in
there's something stitched in latin and
it means something like you who wear me
will know me or something like that it
says like on the inside
so sheila gets talked into buying this
dress even though it's not something she
would usually wear because she seems as
i said she seems very like modest very
dowdy and this is like a bright red
dress and it's a little bit low-cut and
she's talking about isn't it a little
you know risque and things like that
and so but she gets talked into buying
it
and the sales lady is like oh this date
that you're going on tonight you know he
will compliment you and also just in the
weird [ __ ] way that they talk i don't
want to spoil it too much because like
this movie is so [ __ ] weird and it's
like if you're really really into
really bizarro [ __ ] and like i said if
you liked barbarian sound studio you
like these kind of like weird surreal
like homages to like old kind of like
european type films like from the 60s
and 70s then you'll probably really dig
this don't expect it to make total sense
because it doesn't um it does have a lot
of
dreamlike kind of [ __ ] a lot of weird
like freudian kind of symbolism and
stuff that isn't really explained so
know that going into it it does have a
narrative it does have a story but
there's a lot of other little weird [ __ ]
going on around the margins that
doesn't really make any sense or isn't
really explained but that's kind of what
made me love this movie you know so i'm
just telling you that going in
so she wears this dress to the first
date and the first guy whose name is
adonis
is
a real [ __ ] prize by which i mean
he's totally not um so yeah so that
doesn't really go all that well
so
after that though pretty much
immediately she starts to
suspect
that something is wrong with this dress
like it's nothing real overt at first
but she starts kind of maybe hearing
um you know the the hangers like kind of
jingling weirdly like in her wardrobe
sometimes the dress is like on the floor
in her son's room even though he insists
that him and his girlfriend didn't touch
it so it's kind of like seems like it's
moving around on its own
and then kind of a big thing happens
where she puts it in the washing machine
like to wash it and
pretty much it tears the entire washing
machine but like the washing machine
just starts shaking chicken that it just
basically like falls to pieces and like
all this like blood and [ __ ] comes out
the bottom or she actually ends up
cutting her arm like while she's trying
to stop the uh the washing machine from
doing all this stuff
so she starts to think something is the
matter now wearing the dress she does
actually go on a second date
and ends up meeting a guy named zach
and they kind of fall into a
relationship interestingly fun fact zack
is played by
barry adamson who's actually better
known as a
musician and he was in magazine he was
in the birthday party he was in uh he's
nick cave in the bad seeds and uh he
also did a really awesome album probably
gosh i want to say it was back in the
early 2000s maybe late 90s called
edipush metapis which is actually like a
really good album but i didn't actually
know that he did any acting but i saw
his name in the credits and i was like
barry i was like that barry adamson like
nick came in the bad seas barry adamson
and indeed it is so i thought that was
kind of cool but yeah he's not a major
part but he is in it so he's playing uh
sheila's you know new love interest
so again you know she i think what kind
of tips it is that she's out walking
with zach and she's wearing the dress
and she randomly gets attacked by a dog
like it kind of like jumps at her and
tries to like rip the dress off her and
then her son like finds the dress later
and it's magically kind of restored
itself so at that point she's like yeah
[ __ ] this there's something really the
matter with this dress
so she tries to take it back to the
store but they won't take it it's like
this big huge rigmarole i forgot to
mention too that
what you don't see is like sheila's kind
of life with her dress and
her suspecting like there's some weird
[ __ ] going on with it they're also
showing you some weird [ __ ] that's going
on in this department store
uh behind the scenes so you're kind of
led to believe i've seen this called
suspiria in a department store which
i totally get that it does have a very
suspiria-esque vibe to it in the sense
that all the sales ladies that work
there are kind of like a coven of
witches sort of they don't overtly say
that but they all dress alike they all
have these weird like like they're
trying to like hypnotize you or put a
spell on you or something like that and
like the way they talk and also there's
the guy that
you're presuming is the manager or the
owner of the store who's this creepy
looking
[ __ ] dude who you could say is maybe
he's the devil or something like that
maybe these are all kind of like i said
it's not overt but you can read into it
if you want to but there's all this
weird [ __ ] going on where
there's you know there's this one really
weird scene where miss luckmore like the
main uh lady she goes back behind the
scenes and like takes off her bouffant
so she's like bald and then she kind of
like curls herself up and puts herself
into this like elevator dumb waiter
thing
and there's also this weird [ __ ] with
like the mannequins and it's almost kind
of like suggested that maybe are they
bringing the mannequins to life because
there's just one super super bizarro
scene where her and one of the other
sales ladies they get this mannequin and
they lay her down on the floor and she
just has kind of like
like black lingerie on or something and
then they start like
right like one of the sales ladies like
sits on the mannequin's face that she's
like should caressing her boobs or
whatever and then they start like
caressing like her crotch and then like
they pull
like the underwear off and then she has
pubic hair and then like the
mannequins like vagina starts to bleed
and then like the old guy that runs the
store is like watching and like jerking
it it's like it's super weird there's
like i said there's a lot of really
freudian like fetishistic it's a very
fetishistic
movie and i kind of feel like maybe
that's
again what he says i read an interview
with peter strickland where he was
talking about this movie and he said one
of the ideas he said i remember when i
was a kid and there was this one
department store i think it's called
jackson's i don't think it's there
anymore uh where he grew up i think you
grew up in uh reading
and
uh so he said i remember being dragged
there by my mom and these department
stores being these kind of like
you know like these wonderful magical
places but also something kind of
sinister about them and he said and i
was also really interested in the
concept of like secondhand stores like
secondhand clothing and he's like i
always found it really interesting that
you're buying these clothes and you
don't know who had them before like they
could be dead
and uh you know it's like and you don't
know them but like you can still like
smell them like with their bo on it
stuff which is a very intimate uh kind
of thing for somebody that you don't
know so that again like our kind of like
fetishistic uh relationship with
clothing and also he's it's not i don't
know if it's it's kind of satirical i
guess because he's talking about kind of
like a satire of like consumerism
because there definitely is
some [ __ ] with like the people um
because this is set actually during the
january sales which is not a thing in
the us but i know it's like a big thing
in the uk like after christmas like
everybody wants to buy everything i
guess it's kind of more like equivalent
to in the us like the day after
thanksgiving which is black friday which
is when everybody does all their
christmas shopping because everything's
super super cheap so it's kind of the
same situation in the uk but it's after
christmas and so it's january sales so
that's when this uh when this is set
during the january sales so he's kind of
like making a joke about you know all
these people coming to this department
store and they're all just like hopping
up and down like waiting to get in
waiting to get in and then like all the
weird uh witch ladies are like you know
telling everybody they can come in and
then it's just it's crazy and it's just
it's totally weird and then like at the
end which i won't spoil there's also
another thing that's kind of like
reminds me of some black friday [ __ ] as
well and it was like meant to but yeah
so it is a satire of like uh you know
unfettered consumerism i guess and it's
also kind of making points about again
the fetishism of clothing and how
going to a department store and buying
like new clothes it's almost kind of
like it's going to solve all your
problems type of thing like new you all
this stuff so it's kind of like um you
know making a little bit of a sly poke
at that type of uh you know concept as
well
so yeah oh i forgot to mention too that
one of the things that she that gets
sheila upset about the dress
is that she finds out
that there was only one of these dresses
and the woman that wore it in the
catalog because she sees it in the
catalog died like she got run over by a
car or something like that and so you're
kind of like let's believe this dress is
cursed obviously
so um about the halfway point of the
movie which is a little bit jarring and
if i had to
have any like very minor criticism of
the movie this the only criticism i
would have is that the second half of
the movie where the dress goes on to
another person those characters are not
quite as compelling as sheila was i
think it was like actually a little bit
more than halfway because sheila's thing
was
most it's not a hugely long move i think
it's only like an hour and 45 minutes
but her story is kind of like you know a
little more than half and then after
like at the halfway point um the dress
ends up in a secondhand shop it gets
bought by this guy who buys it as a gag
for a friend of his who is having a
bachelor party
and they make him wear it
and then it kind of gets passed on to
that guy's fiance
and you know the same [ __ ] starts to
happen to them like you know you get a
rash
and like i said the the dress kind of
like moves around on its own like
there's a couple great shots of like
people sleeping and the dress is just
kind of like hanging like in the air
above them and it does actually try to
like suffocate a couple people it
suffocates like it kills a little canary
or bird or whatever it does that kind of
stuff now again
i don't want to spoil too much about
this because i it's not that old and i
really think if you're really into like
weird ass like surrealist
cinema and you really like
you know old european films like really
weird [ __ ] like that then you would
probably really like this and i'd so i
don't want to spoil too much of what
happens like i said it does have a plot
it is about the dress and it being
cursed but it has like so much other
it's just like rich with all this weird
like
symbolic detail and like i said you can
kind of
read it in lots and lots of different
ways which is one thing that's really
awesome about it and like i said this is
definitely one that i'm gonna do like a
second re-watch on but yeah there's just
so much
weird-ass
goodness in this movie like the sound
design is so awesome like the score is
really awesome
the visuals are just so
striking
uh it's just a bizarre bizarre flick
like i said if you're into giallo stuff
if you're into anything like that that
has that sort of sensibility to it
then you probably really really like
this like i said it also it has a very
british thing too like almost like a
weird-ass
hammer film but filtered through
giallo and filtered through maybe like
surrealist
kind of like i said like like a ken
russell or something like that it's just
like it's so so hard to describe
and
the humor is really hard to describe too
um some of the funniest [ __ ] in it is
just random like i said the two guys
that that run the bank and they're kind
of in the second part too because it
turns out that they know
the second guy reg who gets hold of the
dress
because it's his bachelor party
and he goes there for a loan and like
talks to them and just like the weird
[ __ ] that they say
it's just
i can't even explain it uh so that is
like hilarious all of the [ __ ] um you
know the sales girl like sales lady like
miss luckmore like all the bizarre ass
baroque [ __ ] she says and like the whole
i just love how they talk like that in
the store like they're talking to the
customers and everyone's just acting
like it's normal it's just like i don't
know that was like really funny to me
but there's just like so many little
touches like that and just so much
bizarre there's like all this weird [ __ ]
about dreams like a lot of people like
relating their dreams to other people
and then they like show you the dream
like one girl has a dream that she's
like i dreamed i was looking through the
catalog in the in the department store
and
i and every picture was of me but then
as it went on like the dress sizes got
bigger and bigger and i got thinner and
thinner and then
you know i died and got buried in the
store like in this big elaborate coffin
and then like her uh fiance has a dream
that that he's like watching her give
birth and then like the baby comes out
like with a little bitty version of that
red dress on and he's like flicking the
blink of the dude off it's just the
weirdest [ __ ] [ __ ] and it's just like
it has this just bizarre grotesque kind
of like sensibility to it and i [ __ ]
i love it i love it it was just so
i don't know this like i said this movie
is just like so in my wheelhouse it's
almost like it was made
specifically for me and it's just like
because i didn't know like anybody else
would be that into because i was like
this is exactly has all
every single thing that i like is in
this [ __ ] movie and so i was just
like
i i was just like riveted by this movie
the whole time and like i said i'd love
to see it a second time because
it was just it's so great and i just
really loved like the imagery of it i
just loved everything about it as i said
the only criticism
is that when you get to the second part
like when the dress goes on to the next
person like reg and babs who is his
fiancee when it passes on to them and
some of the same [ __ ] starts to happen
those k it's you know it's still good
but it's just those characters aren't
quite as compelling as sheila was like
in the first part so but that's the only
thing uh and really it's not really that
much of an issue because there was some
funny [ __ ] going on with that too
because like i said reg he's a washing
machine repairman and they have this and
it happens like a couple times like a
gag in there that he's like looking at
people's washing machines and explaining
like what could be wrong with them and
how he's gonna fix it and he's like
talking like in all this like you know
washing machine jargon and it's like
really boring but it's kind of like
every time he does that
every the person that he's talking to
like starts going into this weird like
orgasmic type of revery like it's the
sexiest thing they've ever heard and
it's just like
and it sounds like goofier than it is
it's like when you see it in the movie
it's just like
it's like really bizarre it's like hard
to explain
one i was reading some different um
kind of interpretations of this film
most of them settle on something like
you know the department store is kind of
like run by this coven you know
essentially is what it is and they're
kind of like throwing a glamour on
people like trying to suck people in
there and getting their souls that they
end up like making the dresses out of
and they control the dress which seems
pretty uh obvious from some of the
scenes that are in there because
sometimes you'll have like one of the
sales ladies like doing some kind of
witchy movements and then like the dress
is somewhere else like doing some [ __ ]
too so they're controlling the dress by
some means
but uh another interpretation that i saw
that i actually like a lot i can't even
remember what site that i saw this on
but some uh one person said it it's
actually
funnier and cooler if you see this movie
from the dresses point of view like if
you
imagine that the dress is like a serial
killer
and it's going about its life like doing
different victims because they said
honestly and this this was something
that i was kind of interested in with
the film too
honestly when sheila buys the dress uh
to wear on her date
the dress doesn't do anything bad to her
right away so i'm kind of suspecting
that if you respect the dress
then maybe the dress won't [ __ ] you up
because she honestly doesn't start
getting like the dress doesn't start
[ __ ] with her
until she starts to suspect there's
something to matter with it and starts
like trying to give it away or exchange
it or something like that so it's almost
kind of like well she disrespected it so
now it's gonna like serve it was [ __ ]
with other people but it was [ __ ]
with other people that she didn't like
you know what i mean it was kind of
[ __ ] with like her son's girlfriend
who was kind of a dick and uh you know
who was kind of an [ __ ] to her so it
did try to like kill that girl and stuff
but it didn't try to do anything to
sheila until sheila like
got scared of it and like tried to give
it away
and i think that when it passed on to
reg
he ended up getting it because
the dude bought it for him like as a
joke because they were having like a
bachelor party and they said they made
him wear it so again you know they're
the dress is being disrespected uh so
the dress is gonna like retaliate i
guess and i really and i hadn't thought
of it that way but i was kind of like oh
man that's like actually a really good
way of looking at it like the because
the dress does appear to be like
sentient to some degree it knows what's
going on and so
it stands to reason that you know if you
you know bought the dress and you loved
it and wore it and maybe it would do
nice things for you because they do kind
of imply that when sheila first buys it
um you know that this is going to make
your date go really well which it didn't
but i do kind of feel like
if you
you know respected the dress then it
would magically help you but if you
disrespected the dress then it would
start to like [ __ ] with you i don't know
but i do kind of feel like that was
maybe
implied in the story i don't know if
you've seen it like let me know what you
think it is but i really do like that
interpretation seeing everything from
the dresses point of view rather than
the human character's point of view
because like i said it's almost kind of
like it almost is kind of like an
anthology movie in the sense that it's
two
stories or like two sets of characters
but they kind of like interact with each
other and they're both like you know
because it's set in the same
time frame like i said the you know the
the bank that
uh that sheila worked at you know reg go
loses his job and he goes to that same
bank like the two bank managers later to
get a loan stuff like that so and and
you know there is one part where in when
reg and babs you know she's wrapping
something like babs is wrapping
something up in newspaper and there's a
thing like about what happened to sheila
in the paper so
they do intertwine but it's almost kind
of like two sort of separate stories
with like some threads in common so you
know so know that going in it's almost
kind of like a little like a mini
anthology kind of like i said it's
supposed to be kind of an homage to
amicus hammer type of stuff but in a
more
surrealist euro trash kind of way um
but yeah so i mean if that sounds
anything like uh something that you
would dig then please check it out i
watch it on amazon prime it's not free
you have to pay 3.99 to rent it but
totally worth it and like i said i'm
totally really going to watch this a
second time because i really really
liked it the first time and i'm
definitely going to watch um peter
strickland's second film the duke of
burgundy which i heard is really good
and that's the one that i haven't seen i
have seen barbarian sound studio his
first one which came out in 2012 and i
actually did a review of that one a
while back too but uh yeah i'm i'm
really getting into this dude's uh work
you know let me know if you've seen this
movie if you've seen either of his other
ones and if they're worth watching uh
particularly duke of burgundy because i
haven't seen that one and uh yeah so let
me know what you thought about this if
you saw it and that will do it for this
flickers of fear i will see you guys on
the next one bye